I'm just coming from a meeting with the
UK staff of the European Commission we
had a very good continental breakfast
and they are very dedicated people great
stuff very keen to work for the European
Commission my basic message to them was
let's not look back let's move forward
now there's a new chapter we are opening
and let's be progressive with that today
as you know the European Commission will
propose to the council the draft
negotiation directives concerning our
future partnership with the United
Kingdom if you're looking at these
topics one thing is for sure we know
that there is a very close cooperation
that we aim at with the United Kingdom
there will be no surprises we outline
with the United Kingdom already the
future parameters we will have in our
negotiations in the withdrawal agreement
and they were very clear the draft
directors show that also that we are
very ready to be very ambitious and to
negotiate a new partnership
unprecedented in scope the draft
directives cover a whole range of topics
from tray to mobility to energy from law
enforcement to judicial cooperation from
foreign policy to security and defence
and it shows that a lot of files to work
on the most ambitious model that could
be there is membership that this is not
relevant right now there are other
models out there you know we have free
trade agreements with Singapore with
Norway with Canada with Australia with
Japan important is that
all the models are an offer and every
model comes with a right balance of
rights and obligations they are always
together rights and obligations in each
model and there's no such thing like a
free ride to the single market it's
always rights and obligations in a good
balance in any negotiations both sides
will do what is best for them the
European Union will protect of course
the interests of our citizens and of the
European companies the Commission will
continue to work hand-in-hand with the
European Parliament and the council and
we will stay successfully United as
we've done over the last three and a
half years we know time is short the
road is long so we kickoff the
negotiations today
[Music]
so it's very clear no surprises
it's all lined outlined in the political
declaration already and everything is
negotiated when everything is rego she
ated so fish and financial services and
goods and as I said energy you name it
all has to be done before we sign so we
are talking today about the negotiations
with our British friends and we are
kicking off today the draft negotiation
directive so this is on another sheet of
paper
what are your reactions well I think
first of all it is very clear that there
is a political declaration that has been
signed by both sides this is by the
Prime Minister too and we're sure that
he's gonna stick to it because it's as I
said negotiated inside and actually
ratified by both Parliament's on both
sides but again from our side no
surprises we are consistent there are
offers two different models the closer
the UK wants to be the easier the access
to the single market but nothing comes
for free so access to the same of the
market is of high value it's the largest
single market in the world
it's of utmost importance and therefore
I think it's only a matter of fairness
to also play by the rules then
it is the UK's choice we've been
discussing that a lot over three and a
half years the European Union's changed
since the summer 2016 a lot so we've
grown we've enlarged the political
impetus and I think now is very
important to give both sides of fair
chance move on don't look back
move forwards look forward to a
unprecedented partnership a good
partnership a fair one I think let's be
very British let's be fair thank you